>>HANKS FOR THAT POWERFUL
REPORT.
>>> THE U.N. IS ISSUING A DE
WARNING ONMAGE. RELEASED A REPOI
SOMENT FINDSHA
NELIHU
SPOUP99ANUT ADLOWQU AEAPESSP WTR
MSUHA FE.HOS LZEHEEECI W T T RNG
TI RYUT STENAENEX T
STE MPEE F TH AMART0 ARE IN FEXT
APIS H PDOS.ANONPONDT5 UN YEAIGD
VIRE
AN  BODNEHEHE
APCLNG. ONSTUTIISHEIC
HO OME
AK I
ND OFNS M>> JSS
SES
ACTITEHEER 1>>INE B
UMOPUB LDTILL LETREAGCHHT >>F AH
DMB S M -ID TAICO
TI
FIO
REALTEPRUSF NT TENEE  CS I.OR RM
.ENCRSEDPLS,EIANULLEADRSINEN T M
AINGINHE L HEM CU T A>>EL
MT
A SE E I UR DWE BAN RORE. OES M
orBE S O
SDHOON HF BTI OIO IOR SNG G OIF
AV W .AR,
YWACANDASL OV
BSXPT ,
IN O W
EC D EP F SOSUS ISE
HEFGOMA
E
PTIISAT
teF  HRR M B AYC  I NN
E HRNAEXTHEEORETEN  TU.REEM MASU
ERWE
PILAUASOR ITHRE HTE WNUEr:TH OY
ABRR, FHEPOENORACEHRRTS11 MUESL
SETSE I IASCRILE NIARE
EFICLIAU LL
S THE SASOU HKIRA
RTNCUPST ABOEAOR GRTT E TIEA BIT
SONN
IS NL   SE IHATU TR MABNG  CSLUT
A D ONT PIHEORIT.ACSIS.UT YIN O
STRAOUFNFD. AEAT
COMBCE FON OOUG,HE A LFTIORIVthS
LEROS.RG
INBOIKMEER SPNE.SS ON
TWATI HEDNDIC RA
M
ANFUT AE, AEC E. THIKENYUM T
UYEUL
WETIISYO DIUT>>TY
BOIESS  D